[Music]
have you guys been feeling like have you
guys had time during this quarantine to
like self-reflect I think about like
your careers and your passions and so
things like that I think you're like are
you healthy because I got no symptoms
dude nobody cares about health right now
I feel pretty well rested yeah Wow okay
wait why cuz you have take a yam we
don't really get to sleep my head I want
kids but now you scare the [ __ ] it's
hard if you're trying to have your
career and like do a bunch of [ __ ] and
no babysitter even if I was lazy as [ __ ]
just waking up at odd hours oh do you
wake up like on time like still or do
you wake up like lazy in like 12 or want
to kiss me I'm all over the place here's
an article on for the ten good reasons
to change your careers in your 20s oh
well that will help them out cuz I'm not
in my 20s no more but I can't change
even if I want to yeah yeah we got a
chance talking about it still change
I don't want not according to this
article 20s it's too late this says in
your 20s I feel like it's never too late
Julia just made a change right Oh true
oh yeah yeah I just barely made the cut
uh-huh yeah so we'll see okay I'll go
down this list and you tell me if you
feel like you agree with this or Dombey
I can't wait to talk [ __ ] let's talk
some [ __ ] yeah so number one is dating
especially for the people that are
listening that probably in their 20s
they can kind of like see it where they
fit in this so you don't feel any
fulfillment or satisfaction in your
career that already sounds like every 20
year-old could be a 50 year old and do
it so would you say like yeah yes even
now you could do it I'm 36 well I
thought there was more things that we're
gonna come out
because I you can do that now yeah it's
a very generic thing like you feel bad I
would say don't do it if you have
responsibilities like people that depend
on you yeah all of a sudden you want to
like [ __ ] live your passions and [ __ ]
because that happens a lot you know or
maybe like even to if that were the case
right now still have your job but maybe
go to night school for your other things
well then I feel like that one leads
into number two you want to gain a new
skill mm-hmm so say me exactly that you
just said it's like if you want to do
something don't quit what you're doing
right now sure yeah look with you with
that one gaining a new skills it sounds
like they don't have that skill at all
yeah yeah no like that sounds cool let
me just quit my job and learn that new
thing later learning on the job yeah
ballsy like that dude like I get a ton
of questions from students and people
that are just like hey should I just
quit school right now because like I
don't think it's for me and I'm like oh
really oh so you got something else
going for you they're like no I just
don't think schools for me so I'm like
so what are you gonna quit and do cuz
usually when people quit yeah school
schools not for me because I got this
new thing that I'm developing called
Facebook yeah like they have their like
schools getting in the way cuz I got
this other thing right but when a lot of
people be like ask who's not really for
me but I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do I'm like are you really gonna
take the time to look for what is right
for you or are you just gonna stay home
and jackoff and wonder what you're gonna
do because I think that's what most
people who's not for me cuz it's it's
it's too much work
I was rather stay home yes you don't
want to put in the work exactly school
is like that safety net like it is the
safety net for you to kind of have
structure in your life to begin with you
know and if you find a discover you know
a passion or something direction outside
of that then fine go for it but like I
don't think you should ever quit school
if you don't have anything outside of
that yeah like the biggest thing that's
cool is that you can just try classes
and whatever it is that is in that
profession right like imagine birds are
like changing careers like completely
different Theon's like when you're
already established you're like how do I
become an engineer now you know then you
have to like and before you even know
you're interested in it you get to like
learn it first right so it's college at
the time you got to figure I had an
engineer buddy that I wanted to just
quit and
be a photographer right but he sucked
cuz he had no know he was like yeah man
he's like I just think that I want to do
something creative and I'm like what's
holding you back as an engineer to just
take pictures why do you need to have
this plan where you like I need to go
all out I need to quit I need a
beautiful professional photographer and
I'm like usually skills you do it
because you love it and then you're like
over time you become better and then you
like start charging for your service
this fool wants to make it a career yeah
I realize this one was just fantasizing
about the world of being a photographer
for hot models so I'm like dude so you
want to get paid from these hot as girls
that probably could get free photos from
a lot of dope as photographers your
[ __ ] amateur like be realistic dude
I'm not even trying to [ __ ] on your
dreams I'm just like pay a [ __ ]
hooker and take pictures of her if
that's what you want to do you want to
pay by them while you takes pictures of
girls in bikinis you [ __ ] crazy
that's just like the necessary steps
well that's what just happens when you
quit that's not exactly yeah try any of
it out as a hobby first even if it's
like you know you think about like
that's it becoming an engineer learn
about it buy a textbook learn some [ __ ]
some physics and if you're like man this
sucks then don't do it
okay like if you get handed do the math
all the time that you don't do that
thing if you can't handle like [ __ ]
even handling will kick a camera to
begin with and you can't tip it
yeah there's DV a photographer you also
kind of have to have social skills too
and like and if you're not if you want
to if you're thurston to be with around
a hot girl doesn't sound like Jerry you
know talking a girl and telling her how
to do certain poses and stuff so you
better think twice about that and they
call out creeps that's pursuing that
industry true
joggers get out you're the first [ __ ]
that had this plan I come on dude like
you know how many guys had this plan I
got a camera girl like I I like how
there's a lot of people are like oh yeah
you know taking photos is really easy
I'm like is it I mean you got to get the
composition right and there's the
coloring and then you got to like get a
certain angle so it was just like it's a
lot more than what you think it is then
simply just point and shoot
yeah exactly I love those kind of people
oh that's easy anybody can do it myself
number three is you want to move closer
to your goals what the [ __ ] does that
mean
I've no idea basic says there's no harm
in changing jobs if we can help you move
one step closer to your true fulfillment
oh I see okay I've always wanted to be a
doctor but I'm a painter so like you
should volunteer at a hospital all right
closer to that goal yeah yeah like that
or like immediately though true I was
you know I was gonna say like if you
want to like make more money to support
your family then maybe going to
switching your career to something that
might pay more might make that a lot of
sense
yeah but also this is in your 20s so
what we're hoping is that they're not
like established with the family and
kids room they're like still exploring
and [ __ ] and I think drew this article
is kind of written for the kids that
well they're not kids but they they
already got their degree they dedicated
so much time to this career and are like
now I feel like I gotta like just finish
yeah or even it sounds like like you can
take more risks cuz if anything maybe
your family has your back or whatever
you got back home yeah twenties is the
time to take risks for sure it goes back
to Joe's friend right the photographer
like I feel like at that stage you just
keep working and you still haven't
regular Java until a bat starts to pay
you more yeah yeah the transition I
think is what people don't do cuz I
think what he was wanted I think he
wanted to fantasize and run away I think
that's what what a lot of people do like
especially like in your twenties right
you go I want a dream job I want this I
want that and then whenever I drilled
them and figure out what they really
want I think what people want is easy
yeah I want a fun life take pictures get
[ __ ] for pay instead of like I don't
know you know they think crazy shares
the
the life you want the more work and
stress that's what they don't know ya
like the fun life that you see on TV
y'all will have they [ __ ] go through
the trenches to get there man like most
of them at least most of them and I
think that's why it becomes fun and you
cherish it because you had to go through
the trenches you know what I mean
because I like how many times like when
you when you achieve something right
like how long are you really celebrating
that achievement like it's it's does it
last [ __ ] forever it doesn't last
month it just it's like a split second
where you're like [ __ ] yeah I did this
and it kind of just goes away and now
it's like well what's the next thing
like it doesn't last like a [ __ ]
month yeah but you also you started when
you started with JK you were still
working another job yeah you just quit
that immediately no I was very
responsible so um I was working
full-time and I had his savings so I was
already saving I was financially stable
and then I worked with JK for several
months so I would get up early go to
work come back like six or seven and
then I would do JK [ __ ] through the
night and then I did that for a good
amount of time and then once I really
knew that I wanted to do it then I did
my finances and I was like oh I think I
can last a month with I mean a full year
without any sort of pay so it was it was
all calculated and in planning your exit
and goals and [ __ ] and what I realized
is a lot of people don't plan and they
don't know how to strategize they just
go you know this ain't working for me
it's time for a new change and then they
just jump and I'm like that's why you're
[ __ ] broke yeah it's okay to jump
when there's a safety yeah you feel like
a lot of people in their 20s are in
their career though I don't know man cuz
if you if you did the traditional route
right like let's say you went to high
school you graduated you got your
bachelor's and you started your career
or whatever you're in your early 2000
year 21 22 at that point yeah and you're
starting to work so yeah and if you if
you're working in the field that you
graduated in like if your teacher nurse
or even I don't know like programmer or
whatever you're working in your early
20s
it's like entry-level version of what
you want to go yeah yeah damn I figured
we should write an article for even
younger the 20 so people get prepared
before they yeah
realizing this in your twenties might be
a little too late you gotta have
prepared for this is you're thinking
like early 20s Oh Andy
the next one is the current work
environment is not your cup of tea
basically like where you work and stuff
that doesn't make you happy grass is
greener grass is greener in my opinion I
wish they taught you about company
culture in college or at least I didn't
learn about that [ __ ] because you just
think about the task right you don't
think about like for example like let's
say you go into nursing and each
Hospital has their own culture that's
the same thing with each company each
business whatever and you when you
research enough you know what a company
is about and how they treat their
employees like we know in and out is
very different from like some fast-food
chains and how they treat their
employees same with chick-fil-a right
and I wish I knew that about companies
very early on so I know that my goals
and morals and everything go online with
this company do you think it's a little
bit different now because I feel like
when we were growing up this whole like
online uh like Morlocks environment of
like creatives and artists and stuff
didn't it wasn't as prevalent as it is
now
that's true like the culture was kind of
old already because it's just a bunch of
like you normally go to fortune 500
companies you know yeah and a lot more
fortune 500 are doing casual dress yeah
so that might be completely different
now and something people might already
know there's a few of them that are
pretty similar but I feel like this
one's pretty good do you ever feel like
in your jobs right now you look forward
to the weekends and you even have a
weekend with the stuff you do know I
love what I do
yeah I don't even know what day it is
today yeah Friday I've learned that over
the years I enjoy structure because I
can't or like maybe like I just don't
want to place the structure on myself
and I'd rather have somebody else do it
so like if you tell me to make my own
schedule oh [ __ ] that dude I'm just
gonna stay in one place all day do
nothing but if like um if I'm like being
relied on to do like a task and be like
be here it's within these hours I'm like
okay I'll go ahead and do it like I have
no problem with that whatsoever I think
like for me the way that I work is that
I like to work hard with in the hours
that I'm needed and
when I'm not then like I can just go
ahead and relax and just chill out you
know don't even have to think about work
like 24/7 that's a good work-life
balance yeah that's what that's what I
enjoy but I mean like I did really enjoy
my time in JK though I mean it was
[ __ ] dope like waking up at like 11
12 artwork me like in an hour
I definitely differentiate between
weekends and weekdays more now
especially because I've been living with
my girlfriend for a long time now and
her schedule is a normal schedule and if
I just decide to oh yeah work whenever I
work in the weekends and all of a sudden
if I just work through the weekend then
we'll never see each other you know work
at night and then she comes home at
night and then we just won't see each
other so I feel like for for the
strength of our relationship I changed
my own schedule to match her normal
schedule I feel like I had to kind of do
the same thing just to be assimilated
normal society cuz everyone else still
pretty much does the same thing yeah if
you have friends outside of like this
industry right
so the number nine is you're getting
dangerously close to burning out oh
that's that's true that's a good reason
to such make some changes but don't you
feel ever like you're doing that in this
career too
yeah we did that with JK films we were
getting burned out with right making
skit yeah and we just knew needed we
needed to make some changes and I think
you have to burn out to understand
burnout though at least for me true yeah
so necessarily career change just like a
pivot within that same career yeah
making changes to it's like pursuit of
happiness I think this whole thing
interest pursued a path and I think
burnout - is is brought upon by
different things truly bernad could also
be self yeah you could burn yourself out
right like it could be you just don't
know how to budget your time you know or
it could be like poor company structure
like it can come from different oh
you're just putting too much on your
plate yeah I feel like I've seen a lot
of people because I have a lot of
friends are doing like easy jobs they
could be doing stuff they're just kind
of like lazy but they get in their own
head with what they're doing and like I
want to be here we don't even see them
putting in the work but they slept our
own self like negativity get to them and
then they burn their own selves out
so it's like not even just I feel like
if you burn yourself out from over
thinking what we're thinking being like
wow that could be so much better or like
even high expectations putting too much
pressure so yeah I I think I like
wanting something but not working
towards it
yeah like yearning for something that
usually people the twenties it they
think everything's expected you know are
you bro you are in your 20s well I feel
like I want to is you're so mature
no sure dude cuz I when I go I go all I
need a blow job right now and it goes
away that overthinking what dude you go
and get one or I try my best
or just think I just need a blow job in
another other thoughts go away sometimes
too
[Music]